sie muss
es Perspektive gehen ja
[Musik]
Rafael Tomate
aufgrund Mercedes
genau oder das macht mit euch das ist 20
Jahre alt
dass die wieder ins Wort keine
Situation Therapie machen was ich mir
alle eigentlich da für eine
Marke von dem Wort kommen
ja
doof
dass man Menschen nicht
hörbar oder nicht
tolle Reportage und unbedingt mehr davon
es hat sehr interessante Menschen dabei
und ich würde gerne mehr von ihnen
erfahren ich würde interessieren ob
versucht wird gegen den starken
Alkoholkonsum etwas zu unternehmen oder
Alkohol ist die härteste Droge wo man
überhaupt haha
und Heroin und gucken
einfach Dankeschön
und
ich tue
mit Alkohol bedeutet dass ich nicht
und dann bin ich am Überlegen
dir paar Wochen
ausprobieren
danke für den spannenden Einblick nicht
würde es Wunden nehmen was die
BesucherInnen vom Checkpoint sich von
der Gesellschaft wünschen wie mit ihnen
umgegangen wird
was ihnen hilft ein besseres Leben zu
führen
danke
nehmen wieso für Anna eine Ausnahme
gemacht wird bezüglich hartem Alkohol
ist das nicht ein enabling also
Unterstützung
war was im ersten so schnell wie
konsumsatz reduzieren
zu machen
sondern bier trinken ist okay aber das
ist
natürlich
kaputt
Gesellschaft verloren hat und wenn die
Gesellschaft den Respekt für eine
verloren hat
auch und deswegen entspannenden Punkt
wie findet man den Respekt vor sich
selber wieder
wir retteten mit euch selber wie der
streng mit euch oder sanft mit liebevoll
ist gerechnet
ja Tankstelle
von Donut wissen wie offen die Community
war war es einfach mit den Menschen ins
Gespräch zu kommen oder eher schwierig
[Musik]
doch Klopfen der Perspektive
Menschen eine Stimme gibst die
Geschichten zu hören schenkt so viel
Verständnis mich wird der Wunde nehmen
Wunsch
also mit gewünscht ist
das dass ich wieder Kontakte
[Musik]
ich würde mich auf den zweiten Teil
freuen weil es mich sehr interessiert
ich habe selber jemanden in der Familie
gehabt der durch Drogen und Alkohol
verstorben ist und daher sehr stark
betroffen bin wann kommt der zweite Teil
und wie geht es weiter
mit die Januar 24 Januar
Veröffentlichung und was geht du suchst
Perspektive unglaublich wichtig
Checkpunkt
ja ich glaube fehlt außer der Film Hexe
Wünsche danke
[Musik]